a home stove in germany probably burning
russian natural gas
and the same for germany's big companies
this fiber producing plant employs 600
but depends on natural gas when we're
here kind of guys without gas says the
plant director we have to shut down
economic sanctions may bring hardship to
russia
but europe and germany in particular
will absorb the fallout from russian gas
shortages prices have already shot up
and supply cuts would make things worse
um
germany's economy minister has announced
an early warning for his country a first
step before an emergency that could
force rationing for homes and businesses
germany is essentially preparing for a
worst-case scenario here in which supply
is completely cut off at least from the
east much of russia's natural gas is
extracted in arctic siberia pipelines
deliver most of it directly to western
europe because of russia's attack on
ukraine germany has stopped one new
pipeline the nordstream 2 just built
under the baltic sea but germany's
dependence is enormous importing an
estimated 43 billion cubic meters from
russia in all the eu gets more than 40
percent of its natural gas imports from
russia
vladimir putin is now demanding payments
in rubles to prop up the russian
currency and that could trigger an early
standoff with europe
this economist is advising germans to
get off natural gas as much as possible
before demand spikes again next winter
it could get more expensive says this
man but it's necessary to put the
aggressor in his place still the
economic effects felt in europe will
likely ripple around the world including
to canada this is delivering a shock to
european households so overall you're
looking at a hit to consumer pocketbooks
on a global basis and a rise in
inflationary pressures that will almost
certainly push central banks farther in
the tightening direction than they
wanted to go in other words disrupting
natural gas supplies in far away siberia
could speed up higher interest rates
over here
eric sorensen global news toronto